So last time we were focusing on repeated interaction and that's what we're
going to continue with today.
There's lots of things we could study under a piece of interaction,
but the emphasis we're gonna have this week is can we achieve attain how many
achieve cooperation in business or personal relationships without contracts by
use of the fact that these relationships go on over time.
And our central intuition,
where we've already started from last time was perhaps the future of a
relationship can provide incentives for good behavior.
Today I can put it intensities for people not to cheat.
So specifically it's I think an example,
and I'll go back to where we were last time,
specifically supposedly have a business relationship and ongoing business
relationship with Jake.
And each period I'm supposed to supply Jake with some inputs for his business
that say some fruit.
And each period he's supposed to ride me with them and put my business mainly
vegetables.
All right.
And clearly there are opportunities here in each period for us to cheat.
We could cheat both on the quality of the fruit that they provide or the
quantity of the fruit that I provide to Jake.
And he can cheat on the quantity or quality of the vegetables that he provides
to me right now.
Central intuition is perhaps what can work is what can give us good incentives
is the idea that if Jake cooperates today,
then I might cooperate tomorrow.
I might not cheat tomorrow.
Can conversely,
if he cheats and provides me with lousy vegetables today,
I'm going to provide him with lousy fruit tomorrow.
Right?
And similarly for me,
if I provide Jake with lousy fruit today,
he can provide me with lousy vegetables tomorrow.
All right,
so what do we need?
We need the difference in the value of the promise of good behavior tomorrow and
the threat of bad behavior tomorrow to outweigh the temptation to cheat today,
right?
It's cheap if I'm going to gain by providing him with the bad fruit or fewer
fruit today,
bad fruit because cause there's,
I always have to throw away.
So that temptation to cheat has to be outweighed by the promise of getting good
vegetables.
In the future from Jake and vice versa.
All right,
so here's the,
here's that idea on the board.
What we need is the gain,
if I cheats today,
to be outweighed by the difference between the value of my relationship with
Jake after cooperating and the value of my relationship with Jake after cheating
tomorrow.
All right?
And what we discovered last time there was,
this was an idea.
We kind of knew,
we've got to known it since the first week,
but we've some had lost time and somewhat surprisingly,
that life is not quite simple.
So simple.
I in particular,
what we discovered was.